[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 para seguir la actualidad
de la copa américa y la eurocopa a
continuación los titulares
golpe de autoridad francia logra empatar
con portugal en el cierre del grupo f y
se queda con el liderato del llamado
grupo de la muerte alemania debió
batallar con hungría para finalizar en
el segundo puesto y se enfrentará en
octavos a inglaterra
tenemos análisis
manito motivacional españa goleó
eslovaquia y se quedó con el segundo
puesto del grupo que para luis enrique
director técnico el resultado sirve como
envión anímico y ahora la roja sueña con
grandes cosas en el torneo continental
tenemos reacciones
perfección polémica brasil derrotó a
colombia en un partido que estuvo
marcado por una compleja decisión
arbitral sobre los minutos finales del
compromiso en otro duelo perú y ecuador
empataron a dos goles revisamos cómo
quedó el grupo ve tras la jornada
como cada día le damos la bienvenida a
nuestra invitada sara castro directora
del diario 'as' colombia sas hasta ahora
bienvenida me gusta estar con ustedes
mucho que analizar el día de hoy por
supuesto que sí y ya vamos a entrar en
materia porque ayer cerró el grupo f de
la euro de 2020 el llamado grupo de la
muerte en la jornada francia y portugal
empataron a dos goles en budapest
hungría mientras que en múnich alemania
la selección local igualó con el mismo
resultado a su similar de hungría
sara francia y portugal empiezan a tejer
una rivalidad moderna si podemos
llamarlo de esta manera pero en el caso
particular de francia como podemos
evaluar a esta selección que toma el
liderato pero con lo justo dos empates y
útil una rivalidad interesante y hay que
decir que en este partido hubo doblete
de benzema y doblete de cristianos o eso
nos pone en contexto de todo lo que pasó
este francés demostró que le saca mucho
provecho al juego vertical al juego
directo y sobre todo a los spas
pero más allá de lo que logra hacer
mbappe en velocidad también hemos visto
un poco imperial filtrando unas pelotas
a unas distancias que son
incomprensibles para el resto del mundo
yo sé que todos estábamos esperando en
una francia que pasara por encima de
todos los equipos pero siempre hay que
analizar no sólo los rivales sino los
contextos y aquí vamos a entrar a un
lugar común que va a ser repetitivo
estos días y es ahora empieza un nuevo
torneo ya deschamps sabe muy bien cuáles
son las fichas que le funcionan sobre
todo el sistema que le funciona
aprovechando eso los espacios así que
creo que lo que se viene frente a suizo
en cuartos en octavos ya va a empezar a
definir cómo vamos a ver una francia que
empieza a poner el acelerador a fondo en
todos los partidos por otro lado tenemos
a portugal que vuelve a ubicarse como
tercera del grupo algo que ya ocurrió en
el año 2016 sabemos que terminó siendo
campeona pero que podemos esperar de
ésta portugal de fernando santos de esta
portugal bueno hay que decir que en este
programa ya hay que abrirle un segmento
a cristiano ronaldo otro récord que bate
ahora es el máximo goleador en
selecciones 109 tantos superando al
iraní
y entonces bueno creo que tienen a
cristiano este es un equipo con juego
colectivo depende mucho del
funcionamiento en el mediocampo pero
tienen el líder perfecto para una
revolución y es cristiano cristiano ayer
demostró en los momentos en los que el
partido más pesado que aparece la pide
él incluso mete el centro que termina en
la mano en el penal en el segundo penal
para portugal es un jugador muy
importante fernando santos no logra
dominar este equipo no logra dominar en
todos los momentos del partido pero
cuando lo hace demuestra que tiene algo
con que pelear le tiene un partido muy
difícil frente a bélgica es a bélgica de
la que también esperamos mucho así que
vamos a ver sin dudas un partidazo hay
también ya para cerrar de este grupo efe
hungría y alemania
dos equipos que por momentos cambiaron
toda la concepción de este grupo pero
que al final los alemanes terminan
quedándose con ese segundo lugar
iniciando el grupo fue una montaña rusa
de emociones sin duda hungría lo
hablamos durante toda esta fase de
grupos un equipo muy bien parado
defensivamente una muralla y aquí
complico alemania ya lo había hecho con
portugal hasta el minuto 81 es el primer
partido con francia saca ese empate
un equipo interesante que se va a casa
apenas con dos puntos y bueno de
alemania de sudor ex acá termina
salvándole un poco el partido a lo que
ha estado complicado no vemos una
alemania que frente a francia logró
hacer daño pero que luego tiene
problemas también la generación en otro
grupo el en suecia se quedó con el
primer lugar al derrotar a polonia 3
goles por 2 sobre los minutos finales
por otro lado españa se hizo con un
lugar entre los clasificados para la
siguiente fase al golear a eslovaquia
pero escuchemos lo que dijo el
seleccionador español sobre este partido
y lo que viene para su selección
con una liberación es evidente que es un
alivio no sé si una liberación
un alivio sí que lo es no sólo para mí
sino por lo que significa seguir
insistiendo en los mismos conceptos
futbolísticos a los jugadores y que vean
que se puede llegar al resultado de
manera clara jugando lo que jugamos yo
creo que la selección española se le
podrá quejar de muchas cosas pero de que
no va al por el partido de ese minuto 1
hasta el 90 de eso no se le puede
achacar nada entonces este resultado
refrenda un poco lo que lo que buscamos
bien en el mejor momento y nos prepara
de cara a los octavos con muchísima
confianza y tenemos unas ganas locas ya
de que llegue el lunes como podemos
interpretar ese cambio que dio la
selección española después de los dos
primeros partidos a una victoria
contundente del día de ayer hay que
hablar que eslovaquia no sólo puso poca
oposición sino que también ayudó pero
bueno independientemente de eso el
cambio de actitud del equipo es
fundamental y también luis enrique
demostró que haciendo cambios en algunas
fichas también logra un mejor
funcionamiento
eric ar si hay espiricueta
defensas fundamentales luego vuelve
busquets que es la ficha clave para ese
estilo esa idea de la que él habla super
clave de ese regreso y además el juego
de bandas de sarabia yo creo que así
logró esta españa después de abrir el
marcador con ese autogol ser contundente
y no sólo eso yo creo que ellos tengan
una ruptura muy grande con la hinchada
con su afición y creo que este tipo de
partidos son los que logran volver a
unir esos lazos que también es muy
importante en estos torneos
morata sigue complicado con su racha
pero bueno yo creo que esto ya va a ser
un impulso anímico muy importante para
lo que viene en el equipo y sobre todo
eso él tiene la idea o la convicción en
su idea y ésta es muy importante que los
jugadores lo acompañen en ese proceso de
consolidación y sobre todo de lograr
resultados ahora a un solo partido
ahora pasamos a la copa américa porque
ayer ecuador y perú empataron a dos
goles mientras que en el cierre de las
jornadas del grupo pe brasil venció 2
goles por 1 a colombia de esta manera
extiende a 10 triunfos consecutivos la
racha que inició el 19 de noviembre del
año 2019
ahora vamos a centrarnos en este último
partido qué conclusión podemos sacar de
este encuentro que vale decir estuvo
marcado por la polémica si hubo una una
situación polémica pero en general hay
que decir que colombia hizo muy buen
primer tiempo la propuesta de reinaldo
rueda fue muy sólida fueron dos líneas
de cuatro y creo que ya le podríamos dar
el premio al jugador más solidario del
torneo a rafael santos borré que es un
delantero que siempre entiende lo que
tiene que hacer y ha llegar un partido
para ser solidario son muy buen primer
tiempo porque les cerraron los espacios
a brasil para que atacara pero además el
gol no es no sólo un golazo por el gesto
técnico de luís díaz en la definición
sino por la gestación de la jugada es
una jugada que sale de barrios pasa por
duggan que pivotea y luego se abre al
cuadrado
que mete un centro espectacular como en
la juve y creo que eso le da confianza
al equipo en esa primera parte luego que
empieza a pasar que brasil como es obvio
empieza a atacar más y mejor mete a
afirmó que empieza abrir espacios
empieza a ir a colombia y la respuesta a
reinaldo no surtió el efecto que le
esperaba el mete otro volante intentando
cerrar más el ancho de la cancha y ahí
no funcionó muy bien la cosa colombia
por supuesto termina metida en su campo
y ahí viene la jugada polémica en la que
pitan a interviene en medio de una
jugada debería ser un balón a tierra
pero luego ellos dicen que la posesión
no cambiaba y se decide validar ese
primer gol que sin duda saca de partido
a colombia sobre esta situación ya la
federación colombiana de fútbol emitió
un comunicado en el que anuncia que está
radicando unas notas de protesta por el
arbitraje de este partido que estuvo
dirigido por el argentino néstor pitana
y pide la suspensión
del mismo ya entonces es lo que podemos
hablar al respecto otro partido de la
jornada también estuvo marcado por ese
encuentro entre ecuador y perú dos
equipos que prácticamente forman un
clásico dentro de sudamérica sí un muy
buen primer tiempo para ecuador que
luego en el segundo dejó clara sus
falencias y son esas transiciones
defensivas muy interesante lo que hizo
perú y me parece que una figura destacar
y si es la padula la padula es ese
delantero que ha hecho un trabajo
silencioso durante todo el torneo es un
jugador con muy buenos movimientos muy
buenos desmarques y ayer en esa jugada
del gol del primer gol de perú se ve esa
manera como no sólo no sólo hace bien su
trabajo sino que hace mejorar a sus
compañeros este grupo ha sido un grupo
muy parejo ningún equipo logra mostrar
su máximo nivel sino que está en
constante eso consolidación de una idea
así que hay ya hay clasificados pero
mucho aún que ver en los cuartos de
final por continuará la acción de la
copa américa son del grupo a primero
estará el compromiso entre
y uruguay a segunda hora chile se estará
enfrentando a paraguay
a continuación vamos con una selección
de las principales noticias que nos
dejan a ambos torneos
jorginho al atún capitán de la selección
de países bajos pidió a la uefa trabajar
más para frenar el racismo en los
estadios de fútbol su pronunciamiento se
produce previo al choque que su
selección tendrá frente a república
checa por los octavos de final en
budapest donde se han presentado algunos
gritos considerados racistas la
selección argentina que tendrá descanso
en la jornada 3 del grupo se encuentra
en la ciudad de buenos aires para
preparar el partido que sostendrá frente
a bolivia el próximo lunes 28 de junio
lionel messi está en duda para este
compromiso porque ha jugado todos los
encuentros buenas noticias para el
combinado de venezuela en la selección
vinotinto anunció que incorporará de
cara al próximo partido al jugador
jefferson soteldo actual ficha del
toronto en la m ls el ex santos de
brasil se perdió los tres primeros
partidos por su lesión
de esta manera llegamos al final de
diario de copas por el día de hoy
continúen con más de la programación de
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
i